when you're walking around the
department and you talk to your
colleagues about computers how are you
differentiating between this all
encompassing almost everything to
computer and that thing sitting on your
guest behind you with a keyboard in
there so we hardly ever talk about
computers
all right so because what we talk about
is the things computers do and how
computers would do them so so you know
and we will often talk about computing
not that there means through which it's
computed okay so for us we are a bit
more abstract than that we actually
think about more about information and
data and how its computed upon at how
its transformed how that's then realized
and to protect the systems of devices
becomes a second kind of discussion but
surely when your son says to you dad can
I have a computer for Christmas you
don't say oh well you've already got one
in your life ago yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't recommend that as a course of
action for any parent we think of these
as kind of invisible computers and and
the computers that are invisible in our
everyday actions obviously the
everything users of computers people
will pull out and sure laptops they'll
show maybe iPads they'll maybe sure
children's phones and and that everyday
use of computers is obviously one that
most people think of when you refer to a
computer I've heard you use this how
many computers did you say you had a
question before I know it's quite a
failure of conversation-starter of yours
bearing that in mind I find it hard to
believe you've never done the thought
experiment or tried two or heads don't
have someone try to carry out some
research into how many computers did you
see today have you never done it I've
never felt I've asked of our students to
actually try and calculate that and
what's really interesting about this is
is then you get results and you get
results that vary from the hundreds of
thousands but will you end up with is
actually had to be as - does that count
and what counts as a computer so as
passed like
camera see in a computer whereas the
computer than that as in the camera or
was it in the place where it's processed
so you you end up with very kind of
detailed kind of categorization or
debates and these things and actually
the point isn't the answer to the
question its how complex it is to get
the answer the question